[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: We're here in the
Customer Magic neighborhood
with a pretty impressive booth
here, with NASA and James,
the director of NASA FDL
JAMES PARR: Yeah, I am.
NASA FDL is an applied
AI research lab for NASA.
It's a public-private
partnership, which is great.
So it means we can ask corporate
partners, experts in AI,
to help us with our problems.
SPEAKER 1: So with that in
mind, how does Google Cloud
and NASA FDL work together?
JAMES PARR: Well, we
had a big problem.
And the problem
was, are we alone,
which is kind of the big one.
And we knew that you
liked big problems.
So we thought, well,
hey, we'll call up Google
and see if they can help us.
What's interesting
about this problem is
we have scientists who are
fantastic at understanding
the problem, and
enormous data, like data
you can imagine how big it is.
SPEAKER 1: Just--
JAMES PARR: --huge.
And so really we needed a
corporate expert like Google
to help us.
And what we prototyped
with Google Cloud with FDL
is the sort of
relationships and sort
of partnerships
which NASA's going
to need if we're going
to be putting people
on the moon in five years.
So it's really, if you like,
a toe in the water about how
the future should
be, just in terms
of the way we're
solving problems,
the way we're partnering.
That's what we've been
prototyping with you guys.
And that's really what
Google is amazing at.
And I have to say, thank you for
the help you guys have given.
Because we did.
We've done some really
extraordinary work here.
And I think [INAUDIBLE]
is going to take us
through some of the
fragments of what was done.
And this is what you can
come and see at this booth.
We're very proud of the work.
And I'd just like
to say thanks again.
SPEAKER 1: Of course.
I mean, it's great to hear.
It's super exciting to see
this kind of really turn to,
what can we actually do
with this technology?
How do we help people?
And so we're going to
walk through and see
what people here Next can
kind of get their hands on
and experiment with, and
then also see, how does that
help us answer, are we alone?
JAMES PARR: Yeah,
the team have done
a great job of taking
something really complex
and making it really simple.
And you can have a go, and
play with your light curves,
and finding the exoplanets.
So there's some
really cool stuff
to get your hands
on here as well.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
Let's take a look.
JAMES PARR: Yeah, go for it.
SPEAKER 1: So we
just talked to James
about how the partnership
between NASA FDL and Google
Cloud helped enable
scientists to really start
doing this analysis.
What can people here
at Next actually play
with to see what
that looks like?
MASSIMO MASCARO:
Yeah, absolutely.
So the challenge was
grandiose, right,
finding life on other planets.
So how do you break
it down in steps?
So step one, you have to
find other planets that
are outside the solar system.
So we actually worked on
that challenge to start with.
And what you can see here is a
little bit of a representation
of how that works.
SPEAKER 1: Sure.
Let's take a look.
MASSIMO MASCARO: So here you
have one of these light curves.
And the task here you
can do is actually
to kind of classify it by
eye, is this a planet or not.
So as you can see, actually,
it's a quite hard task.
You have to kind of understand
when things are planet or not.
And there are actually a
lot of subtleties here.
This takes actually
a lot of human labor
and a lot of astrophysics
minds actually
spent on this, for years.
So what we had as
an idea is that,
can we actually have machine
learning help us with this.
And so we use, actually,
the power of deep learning
and AI in Google
Cloud to kind of train
a model that does this.
So the researchers did this
actually with our technology.
And actually they were able to
get a model that is not only
more accurate than humans, it
can actually kind of process
entire data sets in minutes,
where before actually it
took years.
SPEAKER 1: So people
can kind of see
the details of why it was
so important to have machine
learning to help out the human
knowledge that was required
to make this happen.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Absolutely.
SPEAKER 1: So for
those exoplanets,
can we take a look at those
in the mobile apps over there?
MASSIMO MASCARO: Yeah.
So like here we have
a very simple app
that you can use to
kind of scan the sky.
And there are a lot
of planets in the sky.
And once you point at
one of those planets,
you can actually
kind of study it,
and you would get the
composition of the atmosphere
of that planet.
So this actually is more
kind of a gamified version
of this that represents
why is this so important.
SPEAKER 1: So this
is like a cool way
to see and kind of get
a little bit of a taste
into exactly what goes
into making those decisions
and understanding all the
technology that's required
to say, look, we're now
making these predictions,
let's see if we can find
somewhere and actually answer,
is there life out there?
MASSIMO MASCARO: Absolutely.
And again, I mean, the beauty of
this is that a lot of this work
has been done by
astrophysicists and kind
of astronomy
researchers that didn't
have a lot of IT
knowledge or AI knowledge.
They were just powered by
both the power of computation
and Google Cloud,
and by our AI tools,
kind of answered these
really, really hard questions.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
It lets them focus on
what's important to them,
and the technology
just helps enable it.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Absolutely.
SPEAKER 1: That's awesome.
Thanks so much.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]